for my ultimate big and bold lunch spicy
Mexican soup it's hearty delicious
robust but served with some tortillas
and a wonderful salsa it's almost like a
complete meal in one starting with some
finely chopped red onions for my soup
let's get some heat going early
these are Chipotle so they smoky rich
they don't come with any warning signal
and these are seriously hot so be
adventurous but beware a nice teaspoon
of toasted cumin oregano dried now start
frying off spices the heat you'll see
the chilies starts swelling up delicious
garlic be quite generous on the oil
because that helps to blow out the chili
right now those onions and garlic on
fire we're gonna balance the sort of
heat from the Chipotle with sugar turn
up the heat and really start
caramelizing that sugar and the chili
gives off the most amazing aroma next
fry 4 tablespoon of tomato puree add I
cannot chopped tomatoes cook kidney
beans and vegetable or chicken stock to
cover that's something quite exciting
about big and bold flavors because in
the restrooms you have to be somewhat
controlled you can't go crazy so cooking
these kind of dishes at home it gives me
that kind of release chilies
particularly when they're dried continue
to swell and release their heat as
they're cooked so the longer you cook
your dish
the hotter will be there's not as
powerful it needs to be yeah and every
five six seven eight minutes and
suddenly it's stronger hotter and more
delicious bring that to the ball and
cook that out for 15 minutes whilst I
allowed the chili heat to infuse I'm
gonna crack on with quick crunchy
tortilla chips and a fabulously fresh
and spicy tomato salsa known in Mexico
as pico de gallo
start by finely dicing three ripe
tomatoes one or two decieded fresh
jalapeno peppers and half a red onion
then chop a good handful of fresh
coriander add the juice from two limes
salt and pepper and a drizzle of extra
virgin olive oil
[Music]
for the tortilla chips rub a little
olive oil onto six large shop-bought we
traps sprinkle with smoked paprika and
gently massage in cut each wrap into
triangles and spread them onto a baking
tray bake for three to four minutes in a
preheated oven 180 degrees until golden
brown and leave to cool to complete my
Mexican lunch I need to finish my
deliciously fragrant spicy soup no spice
is there it is absolutely spot-on now
for the cooling down process the
Mexicans are brilliant at building layer
upon layer of flavor with delicious
chilies and spices but they're also
experts at tempering their dishes with
cooling ingredients like avocado sour
cream and cheese that's why you can take
that amount of chili gun a spoon of
richness spice all of a sudden now
Ricardo's almost like a little fire
blanket over those chilies twofer the
count of the chili heat Mexicans use a
rich tangy crumbly cheese but I'm
sprinting on lancashire which is a great
British substitute
and last but not least cooling fresh
coriander one delicious spicy makes you
consume serve that with your tortilla
chips and your pico de gallo salsa a
phenomenal blend of textures and layers
and spice and creaminess big balls and
delicious a few simple cuts through the
Rhine means the Chop stays flat and
cooks evenly this really helps to cook
the bird evenly because you're pushing
out all the empty spaces